こんにちははじめ社長です2024年
始まってもう1週間ぐらいが経とうとして
います毎年恒例はめ社長1年間禁止何に
する
の今日発表させていただきますまそもそも
初見社長のえ禁止とは何かあのこれ実は
かなり歴史の長いものでしてなんかネット
にもまとめてあったりしますえはじめ社長
の1年間縛り生活とははじめ社長が1年間
何かを禁止したり何かに取り組み続けたり
する企画で毎年年始から年末にかけて行わ
れるその歴史は古くスタートしたのは遡り
2016年8年前ですね深あと2年やれば
点差アニバーサリーこのはめ社長の1年
禁止生活2016年から始まっていますと
当時お菓子を食べすぎて太ってきたことに
危機感を抱いていたはめ社長が1年間お
菓子を食べないと宣言したことが始まりと
それ以降ですね毎年1年間何かを禁止する
ことによって何かを得る意味のない禁止は
1つもしてないです必ずその何をやめる
ことによって何かを得るという自分にとっ
てプラスの1年間禁止生活をずっと続けて
きましたで歴代の禁止を言うと2016年
は1年間お菓子を禁止2017年は
ラーメン1年間禁止生活2018年は肉
禁止生活2019年1年間私服禁止生活1
年間スーツしか切れないという私服禁止
生活2020年1年間1日腹筋300回
縛り生活1年間で合計10万回腹筋をし
ましそして2021年米禁止生活1年間米
食べなかったんですよ日本人の心を忘れ
ましたそして2022年え禁止を禁止生活
させていただきましたもう逆にここまで
禁止しすぎたので1回禁止するのを禁止
しようと自由にする1年が2022年
そして去年2023年はえコラボ禁止生活
YouTuberとの共演を一切せずに1
年間過ごさせていただきましたこういう
はめ社長の1年間何かを禁止する生活って
こう歴史があってあのねこれやってみて
思ったんですけども本当に全部良かった
食べ物とかそういう何かを禁止するのは
すごい食生活を見直すきっかけにもなっ
たりなんだろうな価値観が変わったりし
たり腹筋禁止生活もすごいあの筋肉がつい
て健康な体になれました禁止禁止生活も
なんか久々にこう飲みのみできたし1年間
コラボ禁止もあのすごい自分の動画に集中
できてなんか自信がついた1年だったん
ですけども今年2024年の禁止生活何を
しようかと思ったんですけどももうすい
ません直前まで何も思い浮かばなかった
ですハードル高いてもうハードル高いし何
していいかわかんないし生ハカの禁止生活
だとえそれみたいになりそうなんですよま
それでもいいんですけど本当ギリギリまで
思い浮かばなかったのでXでちょっと聞い
てみました来年の1年間禁止生活何禁止し
たらおもろいかなっても軽い気持ちで聞い
てたんですけれどもとてもたくさんの方に
ですねアドバイスとかこれ禁止したらいい
じゃないのっていうコメントいただきまし
た本当にありがとうございます俺の印象に
残っていたもの何個があるんですけども
例えばこれとかね髭剃り禁止でお願いし
ますああ髭1年禁止とかね部衛星不不衛星
になっちゃうすご見た目がなんか再生落ち
そうあとそもそも俺脱毛してて髭がもう
あんまり生えないお肌になってるのでこれ
はね多分俺やったところであんまり髭ボボ
にならないと思うんで残念です挨拶禁止
ブレ挨拶禁止ブレでもちょっとあありな気
がするなでもなんか初対面の人とかにも
言えないわけです初めましてとかめっちゃ
評価下がりそう人としてのなんか人間性
疑われそうですねちょっと面白いなと思い
ました毎日10kgランニングカフェイン
摂取禁止夜更かし禁止12時までに布団
昼寝禁止お菓子禁止炭酸医療禁止自販機で
購入禁止冷たい飲み物禁止長も禁止靴禁止
長おいさじさん多いです全部やるという
よりこの中で選べって感じなのかなお菓子
禁止とかマジでなんかねすごい健康意識が
変わった気がしたんですよけどやっぱね
たまに食べるお菓子がね
こう自分を動かしたりするんですようん
水分死ぬ水分種は死ぬ他の人のリプ見て
ないですけどダトでインターネット
でしょうね死ぬ死活問題あのネットで生き
てる人間なのでインターネット禁止は本当
にあの何も現状報告できなくなりますこれ
はやばいね根本から立つタイプね逆にあり
いやない呼吸禁止死ぬ呼吸禁止は死ぬな
どういう何を言ってるのYouTube
無理無理ですYouTube禁止は無理
根本的に無理です俺1年間何したらいいの
何しましょう留学とか行ってこようかな
スマホ金でこれはちょっとあり無駄に
スマホ触る時間本当増えてなんか
tiktok見たりYouTube
ショートとかうわってなんかね分かる人
いるでしょスマホ禁止はちょっとありだな
と思ったんですけどもあのお仕事と私生活
仕事に響きます全面的に大ダメージ受け
そうなのでちょっとこれパスティッシュ
ああやばい年中美でこの後春になって花粉
の季節でしょティッシュ使わない1にし
たりともないのでこれもかなり苦しいかな
ない時どうすればいいんだろうって思っ
ちゃいました2日連続後同じ場所で寝るの
禁止ベッド2個あったりこの家時代
いろんな場所に寝泊まりできるんでねこれ
はなんかね割といけそうな気がしましたで
もナイスアンです右折禁止どうしてどうし
てそんなことするのやったところで
メリットを感じられればいいんですけども
ねあ右に来たければ左折しまくって一する
しかないってことそれですウォーキングの
時にやってみようかなと思ってますやろう
としてる人も出ちゃってるあだけどこれも
ねなんかやった上で何を得られるかと言と
右折の大切さなんですよ右折の
大切パス排泄外出禁止俺と同じ発想の人
ですねこれなんか最近思いついたんです
けどあのコロナのそのなんかステイホーム
みたいな家にずっといなさいねっっていう
状況だったら1年間外出禁しちょっとあり
だなって思いました多分ですね1年ぶりに
見る空は広いんですよ1年外水に1年ぶり
に見る空の美しさはちょっとかけがえねえ
ものになりそうだったんですけどかなり
生活に支障が出そうなのでこれもちょっと
ね今じゃないかなって気がしましたコラボ
禁止もうやったマスターベーション無理
女性との会話ちょっとありこれはちょっと
ね面白いと思いましたがなんか怖い話し
たいんですよ女性との会話無理まま
ちょっと面白そうだなも全然ねいや無理だ
な店員さんとかも選ばなきゃいけないって
ことでしょごめん店員さん女性だったから
つっと頼めなかったとか出てくるってこ
でしょだいぶやばいけどな女性の尊さを
知るきっかけになる気がしました口からの
食事どこで取れと基本的人権禁止バカか
妄想の課金お正月に17万課金しました
手遅れ歯磨はマウ書禁止頼もやってくれ
無理汚いってこれやって何の得があるのっ
ていうあ歯磨きの大切さを学べるかその前
にボロボロになりそうでなくなりそうだな
みんな厳しすぎるだろ生活妖精の使用禁止
とかにしてやれよ無理呼吸無理多様性の
認知深い突然深いとこに入ってきたそう
ですねなんか多様性をこう認めすぎた現代
だからこそ何でも許されてなんかわけ
わかんないことになってるような部分も
ありますけども
それ多様性の認知を禁止するとなるとどう
すればいいだもっとなんだろうこここ個々
のそのアイデンティ収益無理絶対欲しい
呼吸とかでいいんじゃねえかな無理なんだ
こいつ何禁止したらかなじゃなくて
そもそも元が言とは真逆にいるコンデなん
だから何したって面白くねえよ存在が無理
こういう発言する時点で君の方がつまら
ないセンスなし笑顔ちょっとあり1年間
笑顔見せないの結構ありだし俺そんな笑わ
ないじゃないですか動画でよっぽど面白い
ことがない限り笑わないので1年ぶりの俺
の笑顔は結構多くの人に感動を与えられる
気がしますが結構おもろいことあると笑っ
ちゃいそうなのでこれはむずいかなでも
結構ありだと思いました笑顔の重要性学べ
そうですたくさんのご意見いただきました
本当にありがとうございますほぼ無理です
呼吸禁止とか何言ってるのって外出禁止と
かはマジで一瞬頭よぎったんですけど皆
さんの意見も元に僕の考えもこう合体させ
て1つの正解今年の1年禁止項目に
たどり着きました発表し
ますはめ社長
は今年1
年
小麦粉食べませ
ん言ったからにはやるしかなくなったな
はい初め長ですね今年1年小麦粉取らない
ようにしてみたいと思います皆さん小麦粉
ってなんだか知ってますか僕もよくわかり
ません小麦粉とは主に食べ物によく利用さ
れていますね目なもので言うとパン麺類
ケーキお菓子など様々な食の材料として
使われてい
ます今聞きましたパン麺類ケーキお菓子
これ全部禁止になります今年終わった終わ
終わらでも絶対いいことがあると信じたい
なんかね世の中にはねグルテンフリーって
言うんでしたっけ小麦粉取らないようにし
てる人もいるんですって小麦粉が入ってる
食べ物ってなんか世に溢れまくってる気が
するんだけど今からいうの全部禁止します
ね小麦粉入ってるんでパン
ハンバーガーラーメンカレーライス
サンドイッチドーナッツ
パンケーキパスタうどんピザとんかつ
とんかつたこ焼きケーキハンバーグ
シチューえ待って何食えばいいの俺何食え
ばいいの
これうんまいっか逆にこれ含まれてない
やつとはってなりそうですね逆に小麦粉
使われてないものはお米お米食べれるのは
大きいビーフ生春待って俺これ食事
楽しめるのか本当にちょっと待って大丈夫
かこれ俺大丈夫かはい今言ったものがほぼ
禁止になりますすごいよ今までのなんか
ラーメン禁止とかちょっとレベルが違い
ますよお米禁止とは逆ってわけじゃない
ですけども米禁止パンハンバーガーとかも
無理です麺類もダメもうこの時点で俺の
好きな食べ物大半もダメなんですよでこれ
なんで俺やろうかって思うとなんか小麦粉
ふるとなんかすごい体にいいっていうのを
なんかネットで見て小麦語含まない食事に
変えたところをお腹の痛みとか便秘頭痛
不眠症目まい成立整理不順疲労感肌荒れ
などが改善されたという声があってで体質
が変わり体重が減少したというダイエット
効果もあるとああなるほどねで小麦ってお
米などと比べると体内での消化スピードが
めちゃくちゃ早いらしくて小麦粉ってなん
か食べてもすぐもっと食べたいとかお腹が
すぐ空いちゃうらしいんですけどもそれを
その食べ過ぎとかを予防できるメリットと
かもあるらしいですねええ日中の眠気頭痛
肩こり病院に行くほどではない不調そう
いった症状が軽くなるなんか全部良くな
るってことなのなんか小麦を抜いたら全部
良くなるみたいなことが書いてあるんです
けども信じられんなわけあるかいやあるの
かもしれないんですけどなんかネットで
どんだけ小麦抜いてこういういいことが
ありますよって言われてもあの他人の話だ
から信じられないんですよエビデンスを
見してくれ証拠は小麦グルテンを抜いて
初め社長の体はどうなるのかこの1年間を
持って検証したいと思いますた1つ心配な
のがあのあまりに世の中の食べ物って小麦
グルテン入りすぎてて間違えて食べちゃい
そうでめっちゃ怖いのでなんかもう
ガチガチのそういうもういやもうそれ
小麦粉それ小麦粉0.01gでも入ってる
んだったら無理ですみたいななんか
ガチガチのなんかグルテンフリーって感じ
じゃなくてもう目に見て分かりやすい
小麦粉を使われている食品明らかな小麦粉
商品はもうマジで禁止にしますだからもう
本当目に見てあ小麦粉食べてるってなら
なければなんか気にしすぎると本当に食
生活がなんか楽しくななりそうなので今
からこれは食べませんていう明らかなやつ
だけ言いますパンうどんパスタ麺ベーグル
グラノーラピザラーメン餃子お好み焼き
クッキークラッカーケーキクレープ
ドーナッツラスクた焼きドラ焼きカリント
まじ肉まんあまここら辺はもう禁止します
食べませ
ん全部好き全部好きなんですココ好き好き
好き麦粉好きだけどもそれ以上に俺はご飯
も好きなので逆にご飯食べてればいいって
ことでしょお米
いける大丈夫かななので今年も何かって
言うと実質お米だけ食べろみたいな感覚に
近いと思いますそれ以外の炭水化物の摂取
方法がちょっと俺思いつかんなんかね
小麦粉ってそもそも日本発症じゃなくて
なんか外国から来たやつだからも日本人の
体に合わないみたいな説もありますがその
知らんやってみないと分からないので
ちょっと僕は今年1年間小麦粉禁止で生活
させていただきますいやどうなるんだろう
本当に俺こっからラーメンもハンバーガー
もパスタも餃子
もハンバーグ
もかなり苦しい道になりますが大丈夫僕に
はお米がありますカルビドンて食べていい
のかな焼肉はいいよね焼肉はいいよね
まあまあなんで本当になんか微量の小麦を
使われていたりする食品って結構あるので
完全にオフっていうのはかなり難しいと
思ってるので今言うと小麦粉で作られてる
主要な食品は完全に禁止しますはい入っ
てるか入ってないかわかんないぐらいは俺
はオにしたいと思いますというわけで
ちょっとね今年お正月色々あってバタバタ
しましたね今日が1月の6日なのでえ今日
1月の6日から来年2025年の1月の6
日まで私初めの社長は小麦粉イコールパン
ハンバーガーラーメンカレーライス
サンドイッチドーナッツうどんパスタ
パンケーキピザとんかつケーキたこ焼き
ハンバーグシチューアマンカレーマン
ビールスナック菓子禁止とさせていただき
ますこれできたら褒めて体調の変化を
ちゃんと言いますから健康よこれで健康に
なれたら何より今年1年はそういう感じで
やりたいと思いますあの最後
に最後のラーメン食べさしてください行っ
てき
ますいただき
[音楽]
ます
うわ
[音楽]
ごしたはいというわけでラーメン食べてき
まし
た最高に美味しかったですとかとかも
良かったんですけども締めはやはり
ラーメンで行かせていただきました意外と
ねお菓子とかも結構あるのよグミとか
チョコレートとかも小麦粉基本使われて
ないらしいのでそういうのは全然食べれる
しチーズも食べれる牛乳も飲める肉も
食えるビール禁止がちょっと悲しいぐらい
かなうんお酒も全然飲めるし意外と甘い
ものでも困らない印象はありますがでも
やっぱね来るのそのハンバーガーとか
パスタとかラーメンとか食べたくなる欲の
がこう来るタイミングが知ってると思い
ますが僕ずるもしないしこっそり食べると
かもしません1年後に美味しく小麦粉を
食べられるようにそして1年で体の体調の
変化とかもお伝えできればいいかなと思い
ます今年も1年初め社長よろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ます
DET